okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p i've
received a number of comments and
voicemails and messages from trumpets
and right wingers over the last week
during which impeachment discussions
have continued to grow and one theme is
people like this furious trump estat i'm
gonna play for you furious
trumpets jimmy from philly who admitted
to a drinking problem and many times
drinks before calling me the he believes
that it would be a gift to trump for
república for democrats to try to
impeach him take a listen to this david
jimmy from philly regarding your
impeachment video i hope to god they
impeach him oh pretty please pretty
please impeach donald trump
he'll just win again when he's in
critical descending yeah there are more
and more serious analyses which suggests
that so many people lack knowledge about
what it is that is transpired over the
last two years that merely debating
impeachment and exposing to more people
the content of the Moller report would
not be good for trump but it would be
very very bad but you know I still am of
the mindset that it is a very likely
outcome that Donald Trump is reelected
in 2020 and gets another four years
which is why you'd better be ready to
vote so I I think that Jimmy is
obviously taking this position he may be
right and he may be wrong but ultimately
it's going to come down to turnout we've
got a great bonus show for you today
make sure you're a member or a patron to
get instant access to the bonus show we
will talk about American sitting more
than ever and why that's really bad for
our health and what I'm doing about it
as well as many many other stories hope
to talk to you then